justement en rapport à cette séquence
j'ai vu que sur internet ça avait été
compliqué pour vous les gens ont été
très méchants suite à cette séquence
comment est-ce que vous l'avez vécu bah
c'est sûr que les commentaires enfin moi
je sais que je regarde pas tout on n'a
pas tout regardé ce qui s'était passé
sur Twitter bien sûr qu'on passe à côté
de chez moi mais non
que sur le positif vraiment on a reçu
tellement on a 80 ans
négatif il y en a qu'on prend en compte
mais après enfin moi je sais que je me
confirme vraiment surprise il y a des
choses qui sont vrai moi
qu'on a fait vocalement un truc qui
était pas ouf et alors en fait on est
des élèves et je suis fier de nous